Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to the last episode of The Restless History of 2021. It's the 31st of December, and as we go through the 12 days of Christmas, Dominic, today we've got two dates from history, both of are you know are not they're not exactly cheery are they well it's every new year every new year's eve my thoughts naturally turn to jean bedell bakasa the leader of the central african republic who later crowned himself emperor go on tom what are you gonna say well no so we've got him uh and then well, I'll save my choice. Go on then.
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。若想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告内容、抢先听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。你好，欢迎收看 2021 年《动荡历史》的最后一集。今天是 12 月 31 日，在度过圣诞十二日之际，多米尼克，今天我们有来自历史的两个日期，你知道，它们俩都不是那么令人高兴，对吧？好吧，每个新年，每个新年前夜，我的思绪自然而然地会转向中非共和国领导人让-贝内勒·博卡萨，他后来为自己加冕为皇帝。说吧，汤姆，你想说什么？好吧，不，所以我们有他，然后，好吧，我保留我的选择。那就说吧。
You save your choice. So I shall talk about Bacasa. So some listeners may remember that we had Tom Owolade talking about post-colonial Africa, the sort of decolonization and then the independent rulers and so on. And Bacasa is one of the bad boys, I think it's fair to say. He's the Caligula of... He is a bit. Is he, do I mean the N the bad boys, I think it's fair to say. He's the Caligula of... He is a bit.
你保留你的选择。那我就讲讲博卡萨。所以一些听众可能还记得，我们曾请过汤姆·奥沃拉德（Tom Owolade）来谈论后殖民地时期的非洲、所谓的去殖民化以及之后的独立统治者等等。我觉得可以说，博卡萨是其中的坏小子之一。他是……的卡利古拉。他确实有点像。他是吗，我的意思是……的坏小子之一，我觉得可以说。他是……的卡利古拉。他确实有点像。
Is Idi Amin the Nero? Yes, I think so. Idi Amin would be Nero. Idi Amin is more famous. Bacasa would be Caligula. I think Bacasa is the kind of connoisseur's choice. Well, also, the whole imperial stuff, the Napoleonic stuff, so there's a slight whiff of Napoleon in Egypt about this as well.
伊迪·阿明是尼禄吗？是的，我想是的。伊迪·阿明会是尼禄。伊迪·阿明更有名。博卡萨会是卡利古拉。我觉得博卡萨是那种行家之选。嗯，还有，那些帝国的东西，拿破仑的东西，所以这也带有一点埃及拿破仑的气息。
There absolutely is. So Bacasa, let's put this into context. Basically, the 31st of december 1965 is when he launches his the coup that will take him to power and in the end to imperial greatness but he begins life in 1921 um 100 years ago he's one of 12 children large families have been the theme of the 12 Days of Christmas because we remember some of you that... So is he Catholic? I would say they probably are. Well, Catholicism is probably there because they're in a French colony.
确实如此。所以博卡萨，让我们把这放在历史背景中。基本上，1965年12月31日是他发动政变的日子，这场政变将他带向权力巅峰，并最终走向帝国的伟大，但他于 1921 年出生，嗯，100 年前，他是 12 个孩子之一，大家庭一直是圣诞十二日的主题，因为我们记得你们中的一些人……所以他是天主教徒吗？我想他们大概是的。嗯，天主教可能存在，因为他们在法国殖民地。
Yeah. So he's born to a village chief in a place called Bobangui, which is a, I mean, I'm reading from my notes, a large Mbaka village in the Lobay Basin. Elaborate on that, Dominic. Well, I don't actually know what that means.
是的。所以他出生于一个叫做博班吉（Bobangui）的地方的一个村长家庭，这是一个——我的意思是，我正在从我的笔记中宣读——洛巴盆地（Lobay Basin）的一个大型姆巴卡（Mbaka）村庄。详细说说那个，多米尼克。嗯，我其实不知道那是什么意思。
Do you? It's in the equatorial forest, it says here. It was French equatorial Africa. So basically in the heart of Africa. The Central African Republic. Right. But this is a very kind of little known part of Africa. Chad, right?
你知道吗？这里写着它在赤道森林里。那是法属赤道非洲。基本上就是非洲的心脏。中非共和国。没错。但这是非洲一个非常鲜为人知的部分。乍得，对吧？
It's kind of bordered by chad south sudan um to various other places it's it's now the central african republic is one of the two poorest places really on the planet i think this and niger are the two places with the lowest some of the lowest living standards so basically bakasa his father he becomes orphaned quite young i think his father was killed in a fight with some Frenchman or something. And he joins the French army, which if you're a self-improving kind of person
它有点与乍得、南苏丹接壤，嗯，还有其他各种地方，它现在，中非共和国真的是地球上两个最贫困的地方之一，我想这里和尼日尔是生活标准最低的两个地方。所以基本上博卡萨，他的父亲，他在很小的时候就成了孤儿，我想他的父亲在与一些法国人等的冲突中被杀了。他加入了法国军队，如果你是一个自我进化的那种人
in Africa, is often what you do. It's what Idi Amin kind of did. You join the colonial occupiers army and then you work your way up there. He's a World War II veteran. He fights in France for the French. He actually fights his way into Germany. So he's been, this is the sort of
在非洲，这通常是你会做的。这也是伊迪·阿明做过的事情。你加入殖民占领者的军队，然后你在那里一路晋升。他是第二次世界大战的老兵。他为法国在法国作战。他实际上一直打入德国。所以他一直是，这是那种
side of, the war hero side of him you don't often hear about. He carries on fighting for the French after World War II and he fights with them in Indochina in Vietnam. And he's actually... All that stuff, exactly. And he's actually given
战争英雄的那一面，你通常听不到。第二次世界大战后，他继续为法国作战，并与他们在印度支那和越南作战。他实际上……所有这些，完全是这样。他实际上被授予了
the Légion d'Honneur. The French think very highly of him. 1960, Dien Bien Phu. All that stuff, exactly. And he's actually given the Légion d'Honneur. Is he? The French think very highly of him. 1960, his colony, his homeland, becomes independent. It becomes basically the Central African Republic. And its first president is a man who happens to be his cousin, who is a man called David Daco. So two years later, B bacasa leaves the french army and he
法国荣誉军团勋章。法国人对他的评价很高。1960年，奠边府。所有这些，完全是这样。他实际上被授予了法国荣誉军团勋章。是吗？法国人对他的评价很高。1960 年，他的殖民地、他的家乡独立了。它基本上变成了中非共和国碰巧是他的表弟的一个人，也就是一个叫大卫·达科（David Daco）的人。所以两年后，博卡萨离开了法国军队，他
comes back to the central african republic and he becomes all this time he's been he's been serving with the french army well serving with the french he's always very close to the french he becomes later very close to valerie she's quite the same yeah um so he comes he becomes the commander of the central african army basically because he's got all this experience. He's only got 500 soldiers, so it's a tiny, minuscule army in this very, very poor country. And he becomes the boss of the army. There are various reports that he insists on wearing all his medals, which annoys people.
回到了中非共和国，他成为了——这段时间他一直在为法国军队效力，嗯，为法国人效力，他总是和法国人很亲近，后来他变得和瓦莱里非常亲近，情况完全一样，嗯——所以他成为了中非军队的司令，基本上是因为他有所有的这些经验。他只有 500 名士兵，所以在这样一个非常、非常贫穷的国家，这是一支微不足道的军队。然后他成了军队的老大。有各种报道称，他坚持佩戴所有的勋章，这让人很恼火。
He wants to show off how important he is. And he also always wants to sit next to his cousin at ceremonies. And other people don't think he should do this. He doesn't like this. There are increasingly heated arguments about where you sit at the president's table. This is why you need a round table. Well, it is.
他想炫耀自己有多重要。而且他总是想在仪式上坐在他表弟旁边。其他人认为他不应该这样做。他不喜欢这样。关于你坐在总统餐桌的什么位置，争论越来越激烈。这就是为什么你需要一张圆桌。嗯，确实如此。
And Picasso takes this terribly seriously and is very put out. He doesn't get to sit next to his cousin. His cousin, foolishly, does not take it so seriously and thinks very put out he doesn't get to sit next to his cousin his cousin foolishly does not take it so seriously and thinks it's hilarious a beginner's error get to 1965 and there's military coups in africa left right and center as the as the original kind of founding fathers of independence are displaced somebody says to daco are you not worried that your cousin,
而博卡萨对此极其认真，感到非常委屈。他没能坐在他表弟旁边。他的表弟，愚蠢地没有那么认真对待，觉得这很搞笑——初学者的错误。到了 1965 年，非洲左右两边都发生了军事政变，随着独立最初的奠基人被取代，有人问达科，难道你不担心你的表弟吗？
who's so cross about the seating arrangements at dinner, is going to pull off a coup? And he says, no, Colonel Bacasa only wants to collect medals and he's too stupid to pull off a coup d'etat. Oh dear. I mean, that is asking for trouble. As soon as you say that,
他对晚宴的座位安排这么生气，会不会发动政变？他说，不，博卡萨上校只想收集勋章，他太蠢了，发动不了政变。天哪。我的意思是，那是自找麻烦。你一这么说，
in Africa in the 1960s, a coup happens immediately afterwards. They couldn't hit an elephant at this dist. That's exactly what happens. So Bacasa decides, Daco starts to build up his own presidential guard and Bacasa thinks, right, it's now or never. You know, I've only got a few hundred men.
在20世纪60年代的非洲，政变紧接着就会发生。他们在这个距离上连大象都打不中。事情正是如此。所以博卡萨决定，达科开始组建他自己的总统卫队，博卡萨心想，好吧，机不可失，时不再来。你知道，我只有几百人。
So on the 31st of December, 1965, he launches his coup. And Daco, the president, is arrested and is taken to Bacasa. Bacasa very bizarrely hugs him and says, I tried to warn you, but now it's too late. So they don't kill him, though. They actually just put him in prison. And so it actually is, by the standards,
所以在 1965 年 12 月 31 日，他发动了政变。总统达科被捕，并被带到了博卡萨面前。博卡萨非常诡异地拥抱了他，并说：“我试图警告你，但现在太晚了。”不过他们并没有杀他。他们实际上只是把他关进了监狱。所以事实上，按标准来看，
Bacasa is not a monster because it's quite a bloodless coup. This sort of message goes out on the radio. Is he kept alive? He is kept alive. So, because he becomes later on, becomes president again later on after Bacasa is gone. So Bacasa addresses the public on Radio Bangui.
博卡萨不是个怪物，因为这是一场相当不流血的政变。这种消息通过广播传出。他还活着吗？他还活着。所以，因为他后来在博卡萨下台后又再次成为了总统。因此，博卡萨在班吉电台向公众发表了讲话。
Do you want to hear his message, Tom? I'd love to. Yeah. He says, Central Africans, this is Colonel Bacasa speaking to you. Since three o''clock this morning your army is taking control of the government the daco government has resigned the hour of justice is at hand the bourgeoisie is abolished they don't
你想听他的讲话吗，汤姆？我很乐意。是的。他说：“中非人，我是博卡萨上校在对你们说话。今天早上三点起，你们的军队已经接管了政府，达科政府已经辞职，正义的时刻已经来临，资产阶级被废除了。”他们其实
really have a bourgeoisie in the central african republic so is he he's a communist is he is he he's not he's just spouting the stuff that people so this is french rather than russian yeah well interestingly one thing, the French are not displeased about the coup at all because... Well, so I was going to ask about that. Because Daco, so they love Bacasa because he's been in their army and he's their pal. Daco had been cozying up to the Chinese, Tom.
在中非共和国并没有资产阶级，所以他是——他是共产主义者吗？他不是，他只是在滔滔不绝地讲人们喜欢的话，所以这是法国式的，而不是俄罗斯式的。是的，有趣的是，法国人对这次政变一点也不感到不高兴，因为……嗯，所以我要问这件事。因为达科，所以他们喜欢博卡萨，因为他在他们的军队里，是他们的好朋友。达科一直在向中国人献殷勤，汤姆。
He'd been trying to encourage aid from China. The French didn't like that at all. The French are, I mean, they keep quite tight reins, don't they? They do. On their former colonies in Africa. They absolutely do. They absolutely do. What you can get from the Central African Republic's biggest export is wood,
他一直试图鼓励来自中国的援助。法国人一点也不喜欢这样。法国人，我的意思是，他们保持着相当紧的控制，不是吗？他们确实如此。对他们在非洲的前殖民地。他们绝对会。他们绝对会。你可以从中非共和国最大的出口产品中获得木材，
but it also produces gold and diamonds and uranium. Well, diamonds. Yeah. Well, diamonds will come up. So Picasso says the army will, you know, new era, all this tremendous. And he's a bit of a moderniser at first. So often some of these people who you think of as tremendous villains have these other sides to them.
但它也出产黄金、钻石和铀。嗯，钻石。是的。嗯，钻石会提到的。所以博卡萨说军队会，你知道，新时代，所有这些巨大的变革。他一开始有点现代化改革者的意思。所以通常一些你认为是大反派的人有这些其他的一面。
So do you want to hear about his modernising? I'd love to. Band begging? I mean, I'd rather hear about the mad stuff. Tom-Tom playing, only allowed in the evenings and at weekends. Okay. So you try to play a Tom-om at three o'clock on a Wednesday in the afternoon, no good.
所以你想听听他的现代化吗？我很乐意。禁止乞讨？我的意思是，我更想听听那些疯狂的事情。打汤姆鼓，只允许在晚上和周末。好吧。所以你想在周三下午三点打汤姆鼓，没门。
You'd be arrested. Polygamy is banned. Female circumcision is banned. He opens a public transport system with three bus lines. Okay, good. That's not bad. And a ferry system. And subsidises two new national orchestras.
你会被捕的。一夫多妻制被禁止。女性割礼被禁止。他开通了一个有三条公交线路的公共交通系统。好吧，不错。这还不错。还有一个渡轮系统。并资助两个新的国家管弦乐团。
Oh, this is wonderful stuff. I'd vote for him. However, there's a downside. He does carve up his finance minister with a razor after a disagreement about the budget in 1968. So that's a low, I think. Well, we can think of a number of prime ministers who would. Yeah, Margaret Thatcher and Nigel Lawson.
哦，这太棒了。我会投他一票。然而，有一个缺点。在 1968 年对预算产生分歧后，他用剃须刀将他的财政部长大卸八块。所以我觉得这是一个低谷。嗯，我们可以想到很多首相会这么做。玛格丽特·撒切尔和奈杰尔·劳森。
Or Tony, of course. Tony and Gordon. Tony and Gordon. Yeah. Oh, my word. Or it's the Rishi. If Tony had only taken after him. Did he literally do that?
或者托尼，当然。托尼和戈登。托尼和戈登。天哪。或者是里希。如果托尼能效仿他就好了。他真的是那样做的吗？
Or is that a slander? Some people say the finance minister was hanged or some other fate awaited him. But there was definitely a disagreement about the budget and there was definitely violence. There were rumours that he was engaged in cannibalism. Well, we're going to come to this. We're going to come to this.
还是那是诽谤？有人说财政部长被绞死了，或者有别的命运等待着他。但对预算确实存在分歧，也确实发生了暴力事件。有传言说他参与了食人事件。好吧，我们要讲到这个。我们要讲到这个。
So in traditional fashion, time goes on and he becomes more and more hubristic and on the 4th of december 1977 he crowns himself emperor of central africa and he basically has this massive coronation modeled on the coronation brilliant throne in the shape of an eagle doesn't it looks absolutely do you know i've always thought i every time i've looked at that i thought if i became um you know if i staged a coup and i became leader of a country that's exactly what i'd do i think if you have a coup that to my mind there are two reputable ways to go so one is to be like antonio salazar who was the economics economist who became dictator of portugal and he was very austere. And sort of, I think you could do that
所以按照传统的方式，随着时间的推移，他变得越来越傲慢自大，在 1977 年 12 月 4 日，他为自己加冕为中非皇帝，他基本上举行了这场仿效加冕礼的盛大加冕礼，饰有鹰形宝座的 brillante（辉煌的），难道不是吗？看起来绝对是——你知道，我一直认为，每次我看到那个，我都觉得如果我成了嗯，你知道，如果我发动政变，我成为了一个国家的领导人，那正是我要做的。我觉得如果你发动政变，在我看来有两种体面的方式可行。一种是像安东尼奥·萨拉萨尔（Antonio Salazar），他是一位成为葡萄牙独裁者的经济学家，他非常简朴。而且有点，我觉得你可以做到这一点
and keep some degree of credibility. You could say, I'm just very professorial. I'm the father of the nation. Or you go the full Caligula. Or you go the full, I'll have a throne like an eagle. I'll give diamonds to people. I'll just go completely mad. So his coronation cost a third of his country's annual budget.
并保持某种程度的信誉。你可以说，我只是非常学究气。我是国父。或者你选择彻底的卡利古拉风格。或者你全力以赴，我会有一个像鹰一样的宝座。我会把钻石分发给人们。我会彻底发疯。所以他的加冕礼花了他国家年度预算的三分之一。
So basically, it also cost, interestingly, the exact amount of aid money that the French gave them every year. He spent the whole lot on his coronation, which was modelled on Napoleon's coronation. Which, in a way, the French must have felt flattered by. Well, they were feeling very flattered because he was giving President Giscard diamonds, which later would come back to bite Giscard
所以基本上，有趣的是，这也正好相当于法国每年给他们的援助金额。他把全部资金都花在了他的加冕礼上，而这场加冕礼是模仿拿破仑的加冕礼。在某种程度上，法国人一定感到受宠若惊。嗯，他们感到非常受宠若惊，因为他一直在向吉斯卡尔总统赠送钻石，后来这回过头来咬了吉斯卡尔一口，
and cost him, some people say cost him, the 1981 French presidential election because this was absolutely scandalous that he was basically accepting diamonds from this African emperor. So even the French found that shocking? Well, they didn't find it as shocking as we would. I mean, they thought it was perhaps
并让他付出了代价，有人说这让他失去了 1981 年的法国总统大选，因为他基本上接受了这个非洲皇帝的钻石，这是绝对骇人听闻的。所以连法国人都觉得这令人震惊？嗯，他们并不觉得这像我们想象的那么令人震惊。我的意思是，他们可能认为这有点
slightly overstepping the mark. But yeah, he's kicked out in a coup in 1979 and Daco comes back. And Daco gives evidence of Bacasa's trial and says, I've seen butchered bodies in the sort of cold storage rooms of Bacasa's palace and Bacasa would snack on them. Bacasa's security chief testified
有些越界了。但是，是的，他在 1979 年的一次政变中被踢出局，达科回来了。达科为博卡萨的审判提供了证据，并说：“我在博卡萨宫殿的冷库里看到了被屠宰的尸体，博卡萨会拿它们当作零食。”博卡萨的安全主管作证说，
that he had personally cooked human flesh and served it to Bacasa on an occasional basis. There were rumours, Tom, that Bacasa had served his enemies to Giscard and other visiting Frenchmen. Now, we know that the French have interesting you know, they'll eat horse, snails. They eat horse, don't they? Yeah.
他曾亲自烹饪人肉，并偶尔端给博卡萨吃。有传言称，汤姆，博卡萨曾将他的敌人端给吉斯卡尔和其他来访的法国人。现在，我们知道法国人很有趣，你知道，他们会吃马肉、蜗牛。他们吃马肉，对吧？是的。
Whether they eat, like, former Central African Republican finance ministers. But I thought these were not true. These rumours were not true. I think they're probably not true. What actually does for Bacasa... Idi Amin did, right?as did right no i mean didn't that wasn't true either i think that's made up okay i think these are all slightly sort of distasteful slightly racist rumors aren't they but they're originating with within african discourse yeah themselves i suppose so yes but bakasa had done he had done a terrible thing, actually, Tom. So listen to this.
至于他们是否吃过，比如中非共和国前财政部长。但我以为这些都不是真的。这些传言不是真的。我想它们可能不是真的。真正让博卡萨倒台的是……伊迪·阿明确实这么做过，对吧？正如……没有，我的意思是，那也不是真的，我认为那是捏造的。好吧，我认为这些都是稍微有点恶心、稍微有些种族歧视的谣言，不是吗？但它们起源于非洲话语内部，是的，我猜是的。是的，但是博卡萨做了一件可怕的事情，汤姆。所以听这个。
So what caused the coup was that at the beginning of 1979, he passed a law that all high school students should wear a uniform made in a factory owned by one of his wives. It's basically to enrich his wife. And when the students didn't like this at all, it was all about sixth formers and stuff. Were they nice uniforms? No, I think they were terrible.ers and stuff. Were they, were they nice uniforms or? No,
所以导致政变的原因是，在 1979 年初，他通过了一项法律，规定所有高中生都必须穿由他的一位妻子拥有的工厂制造的制服。这基本上是为了让他的妻子发财。当学生们非常不喜欢这一点时，这全都是关于预科学生之类的。那些制服好看吗？不，我想它们很糟糕。……学生之类的。那些制服好看吗，还是？不，
I think they're terrible. They're terrible. Okay. They probably very scratchy or something. They, they threw stones at his car and he was very put out by it, including they like lots of kids threw stones at his car. He was absolutely outraged by this.
我觉得它们很糟糕。它们很糟糕。好吧。它们可能非常扎人之类的。他们向他的车扔石头，他对此感到非常沮丧，包括像许多孩子一样向他的车扔石头。他对此感到绝对愤怒。
He ordered his men to round up loads of children and kill them. And that's true, is it? Yeah. Kill about a hundred kids 100 kids you know what's it what's amazing about this um the 12 days of christmas is that we've we've chosen these i mean certainly i didn't think about the various ramifications but we've had a massacre of innocence i know we've got another massacre of innocence this happens a lot in history i suppose
他命令手下把一大群孩子围起来杀死他们。这是真的吗？是的。杀了一百个孩子。100个孩子，你知道关于圣诞十二日最令人惊奇的是什么吗？我们选择了这些——我的意思是，我当然没有考虑过各种后果，但我们经历了一场无辜者的屠杀。我知道我们还有另一场无辜者的屠杀，这在历史上经常发生，我想
amazing isn't it yeah so the french eventually pulled the plug. They thought he was embarrassment and that was enough. So in the end of 79, they got rid of him. But he wasn't executed or anything. I think he just sort of lingered on, died in prison or something like that, or died in exile. He didn't go to France, hang out with Giscard. Should we do some live research? Yeah, do some live research.
太神奇了，不是吗？是的，所以法国人最终拔掉了他的插头。他们认为他是个累赘，这就够了。所以在 79 年底，他们摆脱了他。但他并没有被处决什么的。我想他只是勉强活着，在监狱里死掉了之类的事情，或者客死他乡。他没有去法国和吉斯卡尔鬼混。我们要不要做一些实时研究？是的，做一些实时研究。
We haven't done some live research for a while. Here we go. He dies in 1996. Yeah, that's quite late. So he was tried. Yes, I knew he'd been tried in the Central African Republic for treason murder. He was found cleared of cannibalism,
我们有一段时间没有做实时研究了。我们开始吧。他于 1996 年去世。是的，那是相当晚了。所以他被审判了。是的，我知道他因叛国罪、谋杀罪在中非共和国受审。他被判食人罪不成立，
found guilty of the murder of schoolchildren. He was sentenced to death, but it was commuted to life in solitary confinement. But then he was pardoned and released in 1993, and he lived a private life in Bangui and died in 1996. So he had, I mean we're talking about people with a lot of children. He had 17
被判谋杀学童罪名成立。他被判处死刑，但后来减刑为终身单人监禁。但随后他在 1993 年被特赦并释放，他在班吉过着私人生活，并于 1996 年去世。所以他有——我的意思是我们在谈论有很多孩子的那些人。他有 17 个
wives and 50 children. Goodness. Yeah. That's a lot of Christmas presents. Yeah. There's a nice Christmas theme to end our discussion of the Emperor Picasso. Well I thought that was fascinating. Okay.
妻子和 50 个孩子。天哪。是的。那有很多圣诞礼物。是的。以一个美好的圣诞主题来结束我们对博卡萨皇帝的讨论。嗯，我觉得这很迷人。好吧。
What's next? Well, we'll find out after the break. What excitement. What drama. All right. We'll see you after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
接下来是什么？嗯，我们休息后就会知道。多么兴奋。多么戏剧性。好的。我们休息后见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. The tension has been mounting as we've been waiting to find what Tom has chosen as his New Year's Eve happy celebratory moment.
我们共同主持《娱乐至上》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝秀场八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。随着我们一直在等待发现汤姆为他的除夕夜欢乐庆祝时刻所选择的内容，紧张气氛一直在积聚。
Tom, what is it? It's another killer. It's killed more than Picasso. It's killed more than Herod. It's killed more than the US Army. Wounded knee. it's coronavirus it's uh covid uh because it was on this day two years ago 2019 yeah that the world health organization was first informed of uh there being cases of viral pneumonia in wuhan i thought that this would be a suitably jolly note on which to end the series of podcasts
汤姆，是什么？这是另一个杀手。它杀的人比博卡萨还多。它杀的人比希律王还多。它杀的人比美军在伤膝河还要多。是冠状病毒，是新冠病毒。因为就在两年前的今天，2019年，世界卫生组织首次获悉武汉出现病毒性肺炎病例。我认为这将是一个适合用来结束我们今年制作的一系列播客的欢乐音符，因为如果没有新冠肺炎，我们可能就不会以这种方式开始做播客。我的意思是，我们受到了它的塑造，但我们根本没有将新冠肺炎作为一个历史现象来讨论，无论是它是否会被历史书铭记，还是会像著名的西班牙流感一样被遗忘。所以我不知道你对此有什么看法，多米尼克，你认为这会被铭记为一种地震般的世界性事件，
that we've done this year, because probably without COVID, we wouldn't have started doing the podcast in a way. I mean, we've been shaped by it, but we haven't talked about COVID at all as a historical phenomenon, whether it will be remembered by the history books, whether it will be forgotten, like Spanish flu famously has been forgotten. So I don't know what your views are on that, Dominic, whether you think that this will be remembered as a kind of seismic global event
还是会逐渐消逝。这很难说，汤姆。我认为西班牙流感是一个很好的例子，因为西班牙流感，我记得大约三四年前评论过一本关于西班牙流感的书，名叫《苍白骑士》（Pale Rider），
or whether it will fade and pass away. It's really hard to say, Tom. I think Spanish flu is a very good example because Spanish flu, I remember reviewing a book about the Spanish flu about three or four years ago called Pale Rider
作者是劳拉·斯皮尼（Laura Spinney）。其实是一本出色的书。一本非常有趣的书。当时令我震惊的是，西班牙流感臭名昭著地杀死了比第一次世界大战还要多的人。它有着巨大的……
by Laura Spinney. A brilliant book, actually. Really interesting book. And what struck me then was Spanish flu famously killed more people than World War I. It had a colossal...
而且它一波又一波地卷土重来。我想西班牙流感在两三年内大约有四波。所以西班牙流感臭名昭著，不是西班牙的。我想是美国的，不是吗？是的。
And it kept coming back in waves. I think there were four waves of the Spanish flu in about two or three years. So Spanish flu famously, not Spanish. American, I think, wasn't it? Yeah.
人们认为它可能实际上起源于。我的意思是，我看到有报道说它可能起源于堪萨斯州的某种养猪场。它被美国士兵带到了法国埃塔（Eta）的大型军队营地，并在盟军士兵中传播，然后传播、传播、传播。所以这绝对是 1918 年底德国军队崩溃的一个促成因素，然后传遍世界各地，杀死的人比第一次世界大战还要多，你知道，有些地方
People think it probably started actually. I mean, I've seen things saying maybe it started on kind of pig farms in Kansas. That it was taken by American soldiers to the great troop camp at Eta uh in france and they're spread among the allied soldiers and then spread and spread and spread so so it's a contribute definitely a contributing factor to the collapse of the german army at the end of 1918 and then spreads throughout the world kills more people than the first world war you know there are places
实行封锁，各地采取各种不同的措施来应对。所以关于封锁的整件事，有一些著名的城市案例，这些城市实行了封锁，伤亡人数远少于没有封锁的城市，这些对政府这次准备实施封锁提供了极大的启发。是的，尽管西班牙流感封锁和措施的结果有点参差不齐。所以，例如，一些地方关闭了学校。但我想在纽约，如果我没记错的话，
have lockdowns places have all kinds of different measures to kind of cope with so the whole thing about the lockdowns um there were famous case examples of cities that did lock down and suffered far fewer casualties than cities that didn't and those were hugely informative on the readiness of governments to impose lockdowns this time around yeah although the the results of sp Spanish flu kind of lockdowns and measures were kind of mixed. So, for example, some places closed their schools. But I think in New York, if I'm remembering correctly,
如果我记错了请原谅，但我认为在纽约，卫生人员坚持让学校保持开放，因为他们说在那里我们可以观察孩子们，我们将能够介入并采取行动。如果我们，你知道……儿童面临更大的风险吗？并且采取行动，如果我们，你知道……对于西班牙流感，儿童面临更大的风险吗？儿童面临的风险要大得多，我的意思是，那是一个可怕的转折点，不是吗？是年轻人而不是老年人成为攻击的目标。是的，绝对如此。这就是为什么它在第一次世界大战中席卷了军队，然后当然又席卷了孩子们。因此，许多家庭会失去
and apologies if I have misremembered, but I think in New York the health people insisted on keeping the schools open because they said there we can observe the children and we'll be able to step in and act. And if we, you know... Were children more at risk and act and if we you know were children more at risk for spanish well children are much more at risk i mean that was the kind of hideous twist wasn't it that it was the young that were targeted by it rather than the old yes exactly that's why it rips through the armies in the first world war and then of course through kids exactly so lots of families would have lost
一个孩子或认识失去孩子的人。显然，我认为这就是几乎在想象力影响方面的区别。西班牙流感和新冠肺炎之间的最大区别在于，新冠肺炎不是一种疾病。因此据我们所知，迄今为止接触过血液的儿童一直是免疫的。
a child or known people who'd lost a child. And obviously that's what I think in terms of the sort of almost the imaginative impact. That's the big difference between the Spanish flu and COVID is that COVID is not a disease. So children have, as far as we know, touched blood so far have been immune.
我想西班牙流感的冲击力被削弱了，因为第一次世界大战在此之前已经发生，这是一场视觉上的毁灭展示。对于未来的历史学家来说，新冠肺炎的冲击力可能会因它袭击了一个全球化的和平时代而加剧。是的，我想这可能是对的。因为边界关闭、航班取消、大城市陷入死寂。这令人震惊，因为在那之前，一切都是如此紧密相连。正是这些相互联系使得新冠肺炎能够以如此之快的速度传播。我的意思是，西班牙流感奇怪的地方在于它在集体记忆中留下的影响是如此之小。
I suppose the impact of Spanish flu is blunted by the fact that the First World War had gone on before, which was a visual display of destruction. The impact of COVID, I imagine for future historians, will be aggravated by the fact that it hit a globalised era of peace. Yeah, I think that's probably right. Because it's frontiers being closed, flights being cancelled, great cities falling silent. That is shocking because up until that point, everything had been so interconnected. And it's those interconnections that actually enabled COVID to spread as fast as it did. I mean, the weird thing about Spanish flu is it leaves so little impact on popular memory.
所以，你知道，如果有人在学校里学过 1910 年代和 1920 年代，你会花上几个星期、几个星期、几个星期的时间在第一次世界大战上，几个月。然后就是，哦，西班牙流感也发生了。让我们继续讨论咆哮的二十年代。好吧，我们要讨论 1922 年，不是吗？我想这将是我们新年的第一个独立播客，所以显然是一个周年纪念，那也是《荒原》出版的一年，实际上当你阅读《荒原》时，你确实注意到了它的存在，以一种我以前没有做过的方式，人们扫荡伦敦，是的，这种人们咳嗽的景象，这种疾病，这是一种传染病，是的，它就在那里，在黄色的雾气中，所以也许人们会回顾文学作品、艺术作品，
So, you know, if anyone's ever studied the 1910s and 1920s at school, you'd spend weeks and weeks and weeks on the First World War months. And then it's sort of, oh, the Spanish flu also happened. Let's move on to the Roaring Twenties. Well, we're going to be doing 1922, aren't we? I think it's going to be our first standalone podcast of the new year so anniversary obviously and that's the year in which um the wasteland is published and actually when you read the wasteland you do notice its presence in a way that i hadn't done the people sweeping over london yeah this kind of people coughing yeah this kind of sickness uh it's a kind of lurgy yeah it's there it's there on the yellow fog um so perhaps people will look back at the works of literature the works of art um
但人们，没有人谈论西班牙流感。是的，我的意思是，在 50 年代、60 年代、70 年代、80 年代、90 年代，西班牙流感作为话题已经消失了，不是吗？我的意思是人们……所以我想人们会记住这件事。我认为它将被人们铭记为一种话题，不是吗？对，所以我觉得人们会记住这件事。我认为它将被铭记为一个地震般的历史事件，原因有二。请说。首先是，正如刚才所说，世界比 20世纪 20 年代初要脱节得多。因此，封锁的影响，
but people but nobody talks about the spanish flu yeah i mean in the 50s 60s 70s 80s 90s the spanish flu was gone as a subject of conversation wasn't it i mean people right so i reckon people will remember this i think it will be remembered as as a subject of conversation, wasn't it? Right, so I reckon people will remember this. I think it will be remembered as a kind of seismic historical event for two reasons. Go on. The first is that the world, just saying, has been so much more unconnected than it was in the early 1920s. And so the effect of lockdowns,
政府设置国家壁垒的影响，在地震级上要大得多、得多。而且由于技术的进步，人们能够进行如此程度的封锁。是的。很简单，你知道，你在 1920 年代无法使用 Zoom。不，不，不，当然。所以人们只能继续生活。
of governments putting up national barriers, seismically much, much greater. And people have been able to have lockdowns to the degree that they've been able to because of the improvement in technology. Yeah. You simply couldn't, you know, you couldn't do Zoom in 1920. No, no, no, of course. So people just had to carry on.
而且，你知道，相当多的人可以在后台死去，而社会大众却没有注意到。是的。我的意思是，那是某种残酷的真相。你知道，每年我们都有，你知道，成百上千的人可以在后台死去，而社会大众却没有注意到。是的，我的意思是，那是某种残酷的真相。你知道，每年我们都有，你知道，成百上千的人死于流感，却几乎没有被登记。所以，嗯，事实上，你拥有所有这些关于伟大城市伟大街道陷入死寂的精彩影像，我的意思是，它就在那里，被记录了下来，人们会看到它，它们将作为
And, you know, quite a lot of people can die in the background without the mass of society noticing. Yeah. I mean, that's the kind of the grim truth of it. You know, every year we have, you know, hundreds and hundreds of people can die in the background without the mass of society noticing yeah i mean that's the kind of the grim truth of it uh you know every year we have you know hundreds and hundreds of people die of flu and barely registered so um the fact that you have all this amazing footage of the great you know the great streets of the great cities going silent i mean that's there it's recorded people will look at it, and they will serve as
非常、非常强有力的视觉标志，表明发生了什么。我认为另一个原因——我认为这在很大程度上仍然悬而未决，其影响会是什么——是，中国在头几个月里表现得很不光彩。我认为在一年前被视为非常偏激、皮尔斯·科尔宾（Piers Corbyn）式观点的问题——即它可能是一次武汉实验室泄漏的观点——现在已经被更广泛地接受了，至少作为一种可能性。我认为真相永远不会水落石出。但我认为这将会——我认为这在过去一年里明显使国际对中国的看法变得黑暗。我认为全球人们对中国的怀疑比以前多得多了。我想这可能是真的。
very, very powerful visual signifiers of what happened. And I think the other reason, and I think this is still very much open, what the impact will be, is that China behaved disgracefully over the early months. And I think that a question that was seen as very much a kind of crankish, Piers Corbyn-esque perspective a year ago, the idea that it had been, you know, perhaps a leak from the laboratory at Wuhan, I think is now, it's more broadly accepted, as certainly as a possibility. I don't think the truth will ever be known. But I think that that will, I think that that has measurably darkened international perspectives on China over the past year. I think that globally people are a lot more suspicious of China than they were. I think that's possibly true.
当然，这也恰逢中国对维吾尔族的镇压，不是吗？是的，嗯，我认为这正是其表现。还有香港。所以这是一系列同时发生的事件。我认为会让人们记住它的，可能是政府对它的反应，而不是新冠肺炎本身，因为政府对它的反应显然是——当我说侵入性时，我的意思是它显然字面意义上是侵入性的，因为它迫使你呆在家里，你有应用程序，你有检测和追踪，你有所有这些东西，
Also coincides, of course, with the Chinese crackdown on the Uyghurs, doesn't it? Yeah, well, I think it's expressive of that. And Hong Kong. So there's sort of a series of things at once. I think what will make it remembered is probably the government response to it rather than covid itself so because the government response to it has obviously been when i say intrusive i mean it's obviously literally been intrusive in the sense that it has forced you to stay at home you have the app you have test and trace you have all these things
这些东西在 20 世纪 20 年代显然并不真正存在。由于封锁，它显然产生了经济影响。所以我认为这是一个催化剂。它加速了已经在进行中的变革。商业街的消亡。例如，播客的发展。播客的发展。这其实是一个例子，不是吗？传统媒体的衰落和新媒体的崛起。
which obviously didn't really exist in the 1920s. It's obviously had an economic impact because of lockdowns. So I think it's been a catalyst. It's accelerated changes that were already underway. The death of the high street. The development of podcasts, for instance. The development of podcasts. It's actually an example of that, though, isn't it? The decline of traditional media and the rise of new media.
向网上购物的转变等等，数字经济的发展，所有这些类型的事情——我的意思是它们被新冠肺炎加速了。它们无论如何也会发生，但会更慢，我想。但我也假设存在这样一种争论——我不想听起来像个偏执狂疯子，但有——有——不，我不会听起来像个偏执狂——你知道，如果你生活在一个展示你的疫苗护照的世界里，在某种生物安全时代，我的意思是，这很可能是未来。你知道，我们都可能拥有。嗯，我们不知道，对吧？我们不知道。
The move to online shopping and so on the developments of the digital economy all those kinds of things i mean they've been speeded up by covid they would have happened anyway but more slowly i think but also i suppose there's an argument i don't want to sound like a paranoid lunatic but there's there's um there's no i don't i won't sound like a paranoid you know, if you live in a world where you're showing your vaccine passport, where you sort of biosecurity age, I mean, that may well be the future. You know, we may all have. Well, we don't know, do we? We don't know.
现在说还为时过早。但完全有可能，汤姆，在 2080 年，在你的手机上——如果手机还存在的话——你将拥有所有疫苗接种的记录，你需要出示这些东西才能进入各种地方，特别是如果还有更多大流行病的话。所以在某种意义上，新冠肺炎，因为政府的角色。是的，基础设施正在为此建立。
It's too early to say. But it's completely plausible, Tom, that in the year 2080 on your phone, if phones still exist, you will have a record of all your vaccinations and you will need to show these things to get into various places, especially if there are more pandemics. So in that sense, COVID, because of the role of government. Yeah, the infrastructure is being set up for that.
基础设施已经准备就绪，而且更广泛地说，政府的角色——休假补贴（furlough）、承担巨额债务。我的意思是，我们将成为——实际上，这些将是我们余生都要面对的问题。所以，大家新年快乐。我们已经录制了——所以我们做了，什么，现在在一块录了六集。
The infrastructure is ready, but also the role of government more generally, furlough, taking on massive debt. I mean, we are going to be, those are going to be issues for the rest of our lives, actually. So, Happy New Year, everyone. We've recorded, so we've done, what, six episodes now in a block.
圣诞十二日。这本来应该是一种欢快的、你知道的，有点乐趣、有点打闹的东西。其实并没有，对吧？我的意思是，其中一些是，但是……但你做出了……嗯，你选择了……我知道。我当时在想什么？
Of the 12 days of Christmas. And this was meant to be a kind of cheery, you know, bit of fun, bit of knockabout. It hasn't really, has it? I mean, some of them have, but... But you've made... Well, you've chosen... I know. What was I thinking?
所以我们为这个特定系列的接下来的几集准备了一些更欢快的内容，不是吗？我们有出生和……嗯，我们有一些死亡，但我们有作家的出生。是的，我们有两场灾难在不同阶段袭击了罗马帝国。但我们有……我觉得这挺不错的，因为我们可以画出平行线
Yeah. So we've got some much more cheery ones for the next few episodes of this particular series, haven't we? We've got births and... Well, we've got some deaths, but we've got births of writers. Yeah, we've got two calamities hitting the Roman Empire at various stages. But we've got... I think it's quite nice because we get to draw parallels
在平时不会做的事情之间。无论如何，我们应该说再见，并祝你新年快乐。非常新年快乐。我们2022年见。明天。与圣诞十二日或十三日的下一期节目相见。再见。明天与圣诞十二日或十三日的下一期节目相见。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。若想收听加更节目、抢先体验、无广告收听权限以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
between events that we wouldn't otherwise do. Anyway, we should say goodbye and wish you a happy new year. Very happy new year. And we will see you in 2022. Tomorrow. With the next edition of the 12 or 13 Days of Christmas. Goodbye. tomorrow with with the next edition of the 12 or 13 days of christmas goodbye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad free listening access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在平时我们不会这样做的事情之间。不管怎样，我们该说再见了，祝大家新年快乐。新年非常快乐。我们2022年见。明天。我们将带来“圣诞节的12或13天”的下一期节目。再见。明天带着“圣诞节的12或13天”的下一期节目再见，感谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest is History），想要收听独家剧集、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。